[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes au forum des
arts rue charles aznavour à montigny le
bretonneux un nouveau pôle culturel qui
vient d'ouvrir ses portes voici le
sommaire la ville de montigny le
bretonneux se dote d'un tout nouveau
forum des arts il a été inauguré le
samedi 26 mars regroupant le
conservatoire de musique l'école de
théâtre et deux écoles de danse 1800
élèves peuvent désormais bénéficier de
ces nouveaux équipements vivent à 30 ans
d'art choral c'est l'album inédit de la
fondation bettencourt schueller qui
célèbre 30 ans d'engagement pour le
chant choral dix neuf extraits
d'enregistrements ont été rassemblés le
centre de musique baroque de versailles
en fait partie et enfin les répétitions
se poursuivent au château de rambouillet
il accueillera en juin prochain secret
défense un spectacle immersif avec 600
figurants
[Musique]
je me trouve devant le tout nouveau
forum des arts à montigny le bretonneux
le forum des arts ou charles aznavour ce
bâtiment de 3500 mètres carrés répartis
sur quatre niveaux il regroupe le
conservatoire de musique l'école de
théâtre et les deux écoles de danse
antoine boesch bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le directeur du forum des arts ou
charles aznavour près de 1800 élèves ont
fait leur rentrée lundi 14 mars comment
s'est passée cette découverte des lieux
ça s'est passé avec beaucoup de beaucoup
de joie les élèves attendait avec
impatience
ce bâtiment depuis des mois voire des
années et dont il y avait beaucoup
d'émulation beaucoup de joie tout le
monde a retenu sourire des élèves et des
parents qui rend très drôle dans le
bâtiment alors cette structure est
composée de plusieurs salles en tout 18
c'est l'individuel il ya également un
auditorium et des studios
d'enregistrement est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer un peu comment ces
pensées finalement ce forum des arts
alors il était posé sur plusieurs
niveaux on a en sous sol la salle de
pratique scénique avec les salles de
percussion sur le rez-de-chaussée
l'administration et les salles de
théâtre au premier étage on a laitages
musique avec les salles du conservatoire
les studios d'enregistrement
et de répétition et au dernier étage la
danse actuellement on l'a dit en 1800
élèves en tout quasiment 1000 élèves
rassemblés par les deux écoles de danse
est ce que d'autres enfants peuvent
encore s'inscrire vous vous avez déjà
fait atteint le nombre de places alors
évidemment des élèves peuvent s'inscrire
encore dans certaines disciplines mais
la majorité vont peuvent se préinscrire
dans quelques semaines sur le site
internet du pôle musique et théâtre pour
des inscriptions à la rentrée de
septembre très bien merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre agité le forum des
arts lui a été inauguré à samedi 26 mars
et nous nous avons fait assister à cette
inauguration regarder le forum des arts
charles aznavour à montigny le
bretonneux a revêtu son plus bel écrin
le samedi 26 mars pour les minimes ont
atteint les habitants pouvaient
découvrir ce bâtiment de 3500 m² qui
rassemble le conservatoire de musique
l'école de théâtre et deux associations
de danse on a une vie culturelle
foisonnante sur montigny avec des gens
qui sont très motivés qui ont envie et
on s'est dit qu'il fallait leur donner
l'équipement qui correspondait à 16 ans
s'approprie la salle avec plaisir les
locaux tout est beau donc ça fait
plaisir dans des vrais locaux ont été
éblouis par les salles par leurs
vêtements les miroirs les bars on a
l'impression d'être une compagnie
professionnelle et je pense qu'on danse
bien mieux depuis qu'on est là un
auditorium de 150 places des studios
d'enregistrement et de répétition des
studios de théâtre et de danse le lieu
offre un équipement de meilleure qualité
et adaptées aux différentes pratiques
quand on joue j'ai trouvé que l'
orchestre
était un peu décuplée je trouvais qu'on
entendait plus les instruments on on
avait une meilleure appréciation de ce
qu'ont joué et
bah c'est satisfaisant en fait non on a
eu besoin de prendre nos marques c'est
vrai que ça change beaucoup en terme d'
espaces de revêtement au sol des bars on
retrouve des barres mobiles qu'on
n'avait pas avant un lieu qui permettra
aux trois disciplines de s'exprimer
individuellement mais aussi
conjointement c'est une chance
incroyable d'avoir un lieu où nous nous
retrouvons tous c'est une ruche il y à
des musiciens des danseurs des théâtreux
c1 donne envie de faire plein de projets
interdisciplinaires
au total plus de 1800 élèves sont
inscrits dans les différentes écoles un
conservatoire des arts plastiques
devrait également s'installer sur place
par la suite
[Musique]
josé cache un bonjour bonjour vous êtes
et le maire adjoint à la culture à
montigny le bretonneux
en quoi ce forum des arts contribuer au
rayonnement culturel de la ville je
crois que ça fait partie de ces
équipements
ra rares qui sont installés dans les
collectivités aujourd'hui le rayonnement
il est simple on a aujourd'hui un
équipement qui propose un certain nombre
d'enseignements
qui tourne autour de la musique du
théâtre mais aussi de la danse puisqu'on
a la présence de deux grandes
associations de danse donc c'est toute
cette synergie
et tous ces projets qui vont se mettre
en place transversaux
avec les compétences des uns et des
autres et qui vont nous permettre de
faire rayonner un peu plus la culture à
montigny-le-bretonneux on est dans
l'auditorium c'est un lieu parmi tant
d'autres qui nous servira à mettre en
place des restitutions un petit peu de
tous ces projets qui seront réfléchi et
travaillé de façon collective vous
l'avez dit le but est de valoriser les
synergies entre les disciplines et donc
ça commence dès le 1er avril je crois
bien avec la création musicale aux 10 us
ont dit c'est une odyssée odyssey
oui il ya une très très belle création
musicale et je le pense sans aucun doute
une très belle restitution qui nous sera
adressée le 1er avril est un projet qui
est à l'attention des écoles puisque
beaucoup de classe de
montigny-le-bretonneux vont pouvoir
assister à ce projet là travailler
autour d'ateliers et puis avec 7
cette joie que nous avons finalement
d'accueillir un premier public au sein
de cet équipement là qui sera un public
scolaire
la conception du bâtiment a été donc
donné par l'architecte strasbourgeois
dominique coulon qui avait réalisé le
conservatoire de musique de danse à
belfort en 2015 pourquoi avoir fait
appel à lui
parce que c'est ça nous paraissait être
le plus compétent bien évidemment et
puis avec un projet qui nous a été
présenté qui donne ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui c'est à dire un équipement
hors norme
contemporain en termes acoustique
au top donc il nous semblait évident de
faire ce choix est d'ailleurs c'est un
choix que nous sommes heureux d'avoir
fait puisque le résultat est ce qu'il
est aujourd'hui je crois qu'on peut être
fier à montigny d'avoir un équipement
d'une telle qualité esthétique et
fonctionnel merci beaucoup je devais
cachant d'avoir été notre invité avec
plaisir côté musique à présent le centre
de musique baroque de versailles a
participé à l'album viva 30 ans d'art
choral de la fondation bettencourt
schueller elle a célébré trente années
d'engagement pour le chant choral dix
neuf extraits d'enregistrements ont été
réalisés par des choeurs différents et
rassembler dans un même album
[Musique]
le centre de musique baroque de
versailles fait partie des élus la
fondation bettencourt schueller a sorti
le 25 février dernier un album viva 30
ans d'art choral qui célèbre 30 ans
d'engagement pour le chant choral elle a
sélectionné pour cela dix neuf extraits
d'enregistrements réalisés par des
choeurs qui ont tous reçu le prix
liliane bettencourt pour le chant choral
on est très très fiers d'avoir été
retenus parce qu'évidemment en trente
ans il y a eu plus de loreak c'est
mathématique que 19 c'est une
reconnaissance déjà d'avoir reçu ce prix
en 1997 est une nouvelle reconnaissance
pour le travail de mon prédécesseur pour
le travail du centre de musique baroque
qui beaucoup pour 900 chorale en france
l'extrait sélectionner une partie du
disque vert pour saint-louis consacré au
compositeur baroque marc antoine
charpentier sorti en 2004 par l'ensemble
de la maîtrise du cndd est dirigée à
l'époque par olivier schneebeli
c'était une expérience assez magique
puisque c'est enregistre à la chapelle
royale du château de versailles de nuit
à l'époque parce que dans les toutes ces
églises on peut enregistrer que la nuit
cet après midi là ce sont les chantres
actuelle du cmbv qui ont repris des
extraits de ce disque notamment confites
et bord tibi dominé
[Musique]
et
la musique baroque reste un genre
musical indissociable de l'art choral la
musique baroque sans l'art choral c'est
c'est comme un pain sans farine c'est
pas possible vous là la musique chorale
vous en avez dans la musique sacrée il y
a toujours des choeurs très souvent des
coeurs et à l'opéra aussi dans les
tragédies dans tout ce qui était
représentée sur la scène de l'opéra il y
avait des coeurs et l'art chorale les
choeurs font vraiment partie de la
musique baroque c'est c'est un des
indices de cette musique là la
directrice artistique de l'album viva 30
ans d'art choral a été confié à laurence
equilbey directrice du choeur de chambre
accentue ce et d' insulte à orchestra
parmi les autres ensembles musicaux
présents dans l'album les arts
florissants de william christie ou
encore le concert spirituel d'hervé
niquet
le festival bazarder mot revient pour
une sixième édition à versailles
jusqu'au dimanche 3 avril dans le
quartier de porchefontaine du cirque du
théâtre ou encore aux des arts
plastiques seront au programme le but
sensibiliser les familles au spectacle
vivant dans toutes ses formes
au château de rambouillet le spectacle
secret défense aura lieu en juin
prochain
il raconte la rencontre entre de gaulle
et adenauer au château en 1959 nous
avons assisté à une répétition
[Musique]
de somptueuses 403 pour vous mener
jusqu'aux portes du château de
rambouillet les flashs des journalistes
pour vous accueillir et un voyage dans
l'histoire à chaque pièce du château
voilà ce qui vous attend pour la
reconstitution historique secret défense
qui débutera en juin prochain samedi 26
mars avait vu les premiers calages
techniques on va rejouer des coulisses
et la rencontre présidentielle qui s'est
déroulée ici au château de rambouillet
en 1959 entre le général de gaulle et le
général eisenhower tous deux étaient
alors président de leurs nations les
états unis d'amérique et la république
française
les spectateurs vont passer de pièce en
pièce pour découvrir ce spectacle ils
sont vraiment immergé dans l'histoire et
tout doit jouer comme dans un film ça va
être époustouflant pour les gens qui
vont venir voir ça et donc du coup en
amont on doit caler tous les détails
chaque personnage est important dans le
spectacle chaque personne exactement sa
place donc on doit qu'elle est tout ça
très minutieusement pour que le tableau
final soit exceptionnelle pour les
spectateurs au total ce sont six cents
comédiens figurants ou encore chanteur
qui feront vivre l'histoire au détour
d'une pièce vous pourrez croiser charles
de gaulle jon irwin ou encore espions et
diplomate chacun et tient son rôle dans
la convivialité et la bienveillance
faire de l'histoire quelque chose qui
nous rassemblent et se retrouver autour
de l'histoire pour partager ensemble
quelque chose qui est bleu le vivre
ensemble l'aventuré humaine se
retrouvaient pour se rappeler de cette
époque dans ce spectacle là je suis jon
irwin le secrétaire d'état à la défense
eisenhower du président eisenhower en
plus de l'aspect artistique scénique et
de l'aspect historique c'est une
formidable aventure aventure humaine que
ce soit entre les acteurs les bénévoles
les volontaires mais également avec le
public parce qu on a des expériences
avec le public qui sont extraordinaires
c'est aussi avec le public avec les
volontaires avec l'équipe polaris avec
plein de choses parce qu'on apprend des
choses et on vit les choses ne serait-ce
que d'en revêtir le costume c'est
vraiment une vraie et belle histoire le
spectacle aura lieu sur quatre week-ends
du vendredi 10 juin au 3 juillet au
château de rambouillet et c'est la fin
de ses études culture merci de nous
avoir suivis rendez-vous à la semaine
prochaine dans un autre lieu culturel
yvelinois bonne soirée sur tv5 118
[Musique]